- So Maks and Val,
so out of your many years
on "Dancing with the Stars,"
who were your most memorable partners?
Who do you think?
Not to diss the others,
just who's somebody that stood out?
- My wife.
- Oh, well, (beep)
(laughing)
Good answer.
- [Val] Yeah, my wife.
- This is why you're still married.
Good answer.
- Thank you.
(clapping)
- It's a pleasure,
and one of the biggest pleasures
is the dynamic personalities
and people that you go
through this process with,
and it's,
I don't wanna say a gauntlet,
but it is something that
really brings people together.
And one of the partners that I had
the privilege to be a pro partner
with on "Dancing with
the Stars" was Zendaya.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
(clapping)
She was young, right?
- [Val] She was 16,
and she was just kind
of trying to transition
out of the Disney star.
And yeah, the rest is history.
- Yeah, that's a crazy career, that one.
She's so talented.
- [Priyanka] So talented.
- So Maks, does it ever bother you
that Val won twice and you know,
you won once?
I'm just pointing it out.
(laughing)
Just pointing it out.
- It doesn't bother me because,
- [Kelly] Does he ever rub it in?
- Because he won twice,
my wife won twice,
His wife won twice.
- [Priyanka] Oh my gosh.
- [Kelly] Just holding it down.
- My 6 year old was
in my wife's belly,
I guess when they won together,
so he has half a trophy.
(laughing)
I only have one in 17 seasons.
But, I gotta say that my best partner
was probably the show itself.
- Oh, yeah. Good answer.
- 17 seasons of incredible opportunities.
Look at us now type of thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So we're grateful.
- [Kelly] That's a great answer, yeah.
(clapping)
'Cause people don't know,
I don't know.
That's one of the reasons why I love
being part of "The Voice" too.
It does that for other artists.
Not only the artists you're working with,
but also the coaches.
It kind of lets you kind of reinvent
yourself too in a way.
And that's really cool
how shows allow people
to really stretch their creative muscles
and be noticed in a different way.
- But it's also,
what we kind of take for granted sometimes
is the people that we gathered
in those shows are your core fans,
your core audience.
It's the support system that you have.
Nowadays, social media craziness.
We can rely on people we've never met.
I don't even know where they live,
but I can always get this nice message
that makes me feel like,
you know what?
I'm gonna go out.
I'm gonna do it again, no
matter what the critics say.
'Cause there's people that
really love your work.
- That's why you're really here.
All the people supporting you?
- Yeah, and popcorn.
- And popcorn.
Thank you for grabbing from mine.
Okay, thanks.
- This is the winner for me.
- This is really good.
I never had that before.
- I'm gonna send you some.
- Oh no, I know.
Don't you worry, I'll buy it.
- Get it at Walmart and
Vons and Albertsons.
- [Kelly] I like to support
you, I'm gonna buy it.